welcome to Hannity we're going to break
a lot of news tonight we have the whole
declassification issue we have not
addressed yet now we tell you every
night on this program we are so blessed
we live in the greatest single best
country God ever gave man never in the
history of mankind good friend of mine
berry farmers always said has a country
acquired more power and abused at less
than our country the United States and
also never as a country used its awesome
powers and resources for the Advancement
of the human condition not only our
citizens but around the globe but we
will be the first to say we are not
perfect human beings are not perfect but
what makes this country country so
special so great so unique it starts
with our founding documents our
declaration our Constitution or Bill of
Rights the explicit understanding human
rights they're not government given but
endowed by our Creator and inalienable
rights for every American life liberty
pursuit of happiness Ronald Reagan often
reminded us and pointed out many decades
ago freedom is never more than one
generation away from extinction now from
World War two where my father served
four years in the Pacific to the rise of
communism to the fight against radical
Islamic terrorism right here on American
soil and abroad the American people we
are a good people we have always fought
to protect these freedoms against those
that would destroy our way of life and
many in and out of uniform have fought
bravely given the ultimate sacrifice
defending against threats abroad it is
so critically important that we now in
this tipping point moment in history
that we hold our government accountable
that we prevent the erosion of these
hard-fought all the blood and toil and
sacrifice and expense for our freedoms
within this country if we don't get this
right and protect these principles
America as we know it will cease to
exist and that's why frankly we have
been spending so much time and sounding
the alarm about the corrupt high ranking
not rank-and-file bureaucrats in the
deep state in the Intel community in the
FBI Department of Justice and elsewhere
those that try to subvert the will of We
the People using the awesome powers that
we give them to protect us to literally
in some instances Oh clear Hillary
Clinton of blatant crimes to impact the
presidential election and then try to
impact that election using Russian lies
and then at the end of it using Russian
paid for lies by Hillary to take down a
duly elected president Donald Trump pack
of lies
now tonight all roads are leading to the
dossier you know the names Comey struck
page clapper Brennan all these other
deep state actors they've hated Donald
Trump and many others they have latched
on to Hillary's dirty Russian dossier
and used the phony document in a variety
of nefarious ways even the New York
Times suggesting oh it might have been
Russian disinformation the whole time
that she paid for now call me we know
obtained a FISA warrant he signed
warrant number one that was October 2016
claiming says at the top of the FISA
application verified and true he claimed
that it was true and accurate Brennan
clapper were proliferating the dossiers
lives throughout the government leaks to
the media leaks to Harry Reid struck and
page plotting to use the dossier as an
insurance policy just in case the
loathsome Donald Trump who should lose a
hundred million to zero would ever
become president over the weekend very
serious congresswoman Liz Cheney really
said something that this could be
treason on their part let's listen to
what she said struck and Paige who were
in charge of launching this
investigation and they were saying
things like we must stop this president
we need an insurance policy against this
president that in my view when you have
people that are in the highest echelon
of the law enforcement of this nation
saying things like that that sounds an
awful lot like a coup and it could well
be treason and I think that we need to
know more we need to know what was Jim
Comey
role in all of this these people
reported to him Andy McCabe reported to
him what was commis role in that it is
now inevitable it's not a matter of if
it is when we will all know about these
extreme this accepts the power abuse
these high-ranking bureaucrats what they
did to malign candidate then president
elect and president Donald Trump now
late last week the president rightly
granted Attorney General bar the power
to declassify material related to this
ongoing investigation into the origins
of this Russia which on four separate
occasions the FBI nine-month
investigation the house Intel committee
investigation the bipartisan Senate
committee and now the Muller report no
collusion American people now you will
see the truth with your own eyes and
it's not looking good for these few at
the top that abused their power now by
the way it's not if it's when we're
going to see it then the question will
be who needs to be held accountable and
you don't have to take my word for it
the swamp is in full panic mode today
America's most holier-than-thou super
Patriot Jim Comey knows better than
everybody issued yet another op-ed
calling Trump a damn liar and any talk
of government corruption is quote worse
deep state conspiracy ever now for some
reason super Patriot Jim Comey forgot to
mention the dirty Hillary Clinton bought
and paid for
Russian lie dossier even though it was
him he was the guiding light for nearly
a year and the very basis for the
corruption accusations and now remember
he faces the fact that he swore to FISA
Court judges that it was a verified the
bulk of information and a FISA
application was true of course commies
rampant fires abuse that's not a
conspiracy theory and Jim Comey I've
warned you before you do have the right
to remain silent you should have taken
my advice from the get-go sadly I think
your rage for President Trump and
intense love of the spotlight is really
overcoming every bit of Commons
you might have call me desperately now
trying to shape the narrative so to
clapper and Brennan absolutely tear and
terror inside the hearts and minds of
all of these people because the Attorney
General will show the American people
what they were up to the anxiety is
palpable
tonight the deep stated in full panic
mode they're even digging bigger holes
every single time they open their mouths
frankly sad to watch but important that
we get right take a look I see it as a
very very serious and outrageous move on
the part of mr. Trump once again
trampling upon the statutory authorities
of the Director of National Intelligence
and the heads of the independent
intelligence agencies and I know that my
former colleagues in the intelligence
agencies are looking at upon this with
great concern and worry I wonder what
else is going to be declassified that
what risk jeopardizing sources methods
nobody would risk sources and methods
for them by the way self-preservation at
this moment is now the key of the day
always more important than preservation
of civil liberties and in our our
Constitution rule of law same goes for
the Intel chairman well-known liar the
Cowardly Adam Schiff call bars
investigation a quest for transparency
hold it unamerican the same ship tweeted
this in December of 2016
President Obama can and must declassify
as much as possible about Russian
hacking our elections
rest assured Trump won't and the
Cowardly chef I've offered him four
hours of airtime three hours on my radio
show one hour here why won't he come on
now we have every single lie he has told
you we the American people he's a liar
he's a conspiracy theorist and the worst
part is we now know he's lying a
partisan hack through and who through
and through and we have a lying partisan
hack in charge of the House Intelligence
Committee that's scary but rest assured
Barr is not going to release sources and
methods or highly classified Intel
and let's not forget those that are snow
we can't release this are the same
people that were asking the Attorney
General of the United States bar to
break the law and release the molar
report with grand jury testimony
included that's called selective moral
outrage now we're about to see important
evidence surrounding the biggest abuse
of power corruption scandal it's set the
president declassified it will come out
we will learn the extent of the
government spying efforts into the Trump
campaign also breaking tonight former
Trump campaign associate Carter Page
just revealed that his contacts with the
FBI informant Stephan helper were
extensive and continued for more than a
year spanning a time period before and
after the 2016 election that's right
spying occurred James Comey says I
didn't spy but he signed the first FISA
warrant we're gonna find out how and why
Hillary Clinton's phony Russian dossier
that she paid for they never told the
FISA Court judges that she paid for it
was used against the president and his
allies we also learned about media leaks
rampant bias and just whose inalienable
rights were trampled on and as president
Trump pointed out we could well uncover
the role of some of our closest allies I
would argue probably Great Britain
probably Australia probably Italy but
I'm just guessing what do I know take a
look the Attorney General is one of the
most respected people in this country
and he has been for a long period of
time he's going to look at a lot of
documents some he might find interesting
maybe you'll find none interesting but
for over a year people have asked me to
declassify so what I've done is I've
Declassified everything he can look and
I hope he looks at the UK and I hope he
looks at Australia and I hope he looks
at Ukraine I hope he looks at everything
because there was a hoax that was
perpetrated on our country perpetrated
on the country and as per usual getting
to the truth is not going to happen
without a fight this is now an important
mission for all of us as
Americans to preserve protect our
constitutional rights and liberties look
at the dossier author Christopher steel
Oh he's refusing to cooperate with bars
investigation well why don't we
extradite him
why don't we tell Britain to send him
over it's pretty telling they're given
three years ago Steele was desperate to
talk to anybody and everybody in our
government about his Russian lies and
according to a big new report Sarah
Carter investigative reporter and
journalist AG bar is also facing
resistance from this country's Intel
agencies according to Carter quote this
isn't just about Trump it's about nearly
a decade of abuse inside the Intel
community and Bureau regarding foreign
intelligence collection Authority by the
way with my FBI flag pin there's my CIA
pin that's for rank and file that love
their country and protect us every day
not the upper echelon 0.2%